oh god oh god i'm trapped in the
infinite ikea how long have i been in
here can i get out how can i get out how
can i survive the vicious staff of the
infinite ikea and work with the other
survivors in this terrifying endless
building okay let's start from the
beginning day one i'd come to this flat
pack nightmare with my lovely wife
brenda to pick up some stupid sofa she
saw online we could have ordered it in
but me being a cheapskate and a fool
instead decided it'd be a dandy idea to
head in and pick it up ourselves
even though i can't stand shopping in
these giant stores of course it didn't
take long for us to get separated i was
wandering around just pretending i knew
what i was doing surrounded by
unfamiliar people then
not surrounded by any people at all like
the complete doofus i was i'd somehow
gotten lost just needed to find my
bearings again and then i could call
brenda to come save me but i never did
find my bearings the hours went on and i
was still lost day two my dominant
emotion on this day was nothing more
than sheer humiliation knowing i'd been
bested by a damn swedish furniture store
i spent the night before sleeping on a
futon wondering how i'd gotten myself
into this flat pack calamity i spent the
day searching for food my confusion and
exhaustion increasing by the moment for
a while i even entertained the idea that
i might have died and gone to some
nordic hell that night i went to bed
hungry knowing if i didn't eat soon i
might be found as a skeleton on a dusty
old futon oh god it came in like this i
can't die on day two day three i
continued my journey through the
labyrinthian vowels of the ikea
disoriented by the endlessly iterating
collections of cheap furniture you know
there was something terrifying about the
emptiness of it all this affordable but
impossible to assemble void starvation
has always been one of the most horrific
deaths hasn't it you could only imagine
my relief when i saw the figure standing
a few feet in front of me dressed like a
member of ikea staff i'd found salvation
i found someone who could help me out of
here but when i approached i realized
something was horribly wrong this wasn't
a human being standing before me it was
a monster the being i'd later come to
know is called the staff by the many
people who fear them it chased me
repeating the store is closed you need
to vacate the premises flailing for me
with its long frightening limbs i only
survived a3 because i locked myself in a
closet and just waited while it hammered
against the wood with its fists once the
night was over it left and i was able to
escape day four i was feeling some
intense hunger pangs on this day not to
mention the fact that i now knew there
were monsters out there just waiting to
beat me to death if they caught me when
the lights turned down needless to say i
wasn't in the best headspace and i
didn't have enough charge on my phone to
justify opening up my meditation app
then
i found nirvana i found the cafeteria
stocked full of delicious warm swedish
meatballs you know no food has ever
tasted so sweet to me then this
delicious meal also gave way to one of
the most exciting new developments
gloria gloria was a veteran she taught
me everything i needed to know about
this place even on the first day i met
her she felt like someone i'd known for
years it was her that took me back to
her home in this place a little fortress
made of ikea furniture filled with a
whole community of other people trapped
in there it was like being allowed into
the garden of eden day five and it feels
good to be alive i met up with all the
different people around the camp they
tell me the most bizarre and fascinating
stories this sounds crazy i know but i
get that sense not all of them came from
the same place as me different ikeas in
different countries or maybe even as
nutty as it sounds from different worlds
one guy tony who's been trapped in here
for a year and some change we got to
talking about different vacations we've
taken on the outside he told me he was
from new york and i told him i visited
there once and i'd love going to see the
statue of liberty up close that's when
he told me that he'd never heard of the
statue of liberty you know i didn't know
what to make of that strange little
details aside i couldn't be happier to
be there with other people the next step
would be finding a way out of here and
back to brenda day six gloria and
several others led me out on our first
excursion missions were the goal was to
collect more food and supplies and map
out the surrounding area i nearly jumped
out of my skin when i saw a staff member
standing in our path at one point and
the others all just laughed at me staff
member just stood there classic and
still gloria told me that it's okay the
staff are harmless during the day it's
only night time when they enter their
pattern of aggression so long as you
don't get lost during the daytime you're
generally fine the team often use string
like thesis to trail behind them and
ensure they don't get lost it was clear
they'd been here long enough to work out
systems for every possibility felt like
i was in good hands with him we
collected meatballs and some rugs to
fortify the walls and headed back the a7
this was the first night that we had to
fend off a full-on attack those monsters
the staff came at us in huge groups
pounding at the outside of our perimeter
with their bald fist it was terrifying
as we were fighting them off we tied
ikea kitchen knives to the end of
curtain rails and speared them one by
one until all of them were dead
they just kept coming more and more and
more of them but it looked like one of
the walls to the north of the community
was going to fall everyone around me
started to panic that's when barry one
of the biggest men in the camp grabbed a
hammer in each hand and went outside he
fought like a beast taking on staff
member after staff member tanking hit
after hit it was something to see that's
when he took off into the depths of the
store drawing the staff away behind him
saving us all we never saw barry again
after that but he's the reason all of us
made it past day seven thank you barry
wherever you are day eight gloria took
me out alone today on another search for
the escape that's when she told me about
her sister she'd gone shopping in ikea
with her well over a year ago now when
she was separated and got lost in here
just like me i had a lot in common with
her including my feelings of guilt for
abandoning my loved ones and my drive to
escape and be united with them while we
were out that day we didn't find
anything useful gloria seems sad but
unsurprised the infinite ikea had its
way of slowly grinding you down days 9
to day 17. despite a rocky start i was
finding my legs in the infinite ikea i
started to get to know my fellow ikea
prisoners it's hard to understand and
truly befriend them we went on
expeditions pretty much daily either to
collect new food more supplies to help
build up our community or to keep
searching for an exit to me it started
to feel like we were making progress and
that helped a great deal to keep my
emotions semi-stable but it wasn't the
same for gloria after all she'd been
here for so much longer than me and she
had her sister to consider on the
outside to her these routines i was
becoming part of now felt like a prison
within a prison she was trapped had her
sister forgotten her out there had she
been declared dead or people even still
looking for her and it was on day 18
that it all got a little too much for
poor gloria she snuck out of the camp at
night when the staff were the most
active trying to find the exit
sadly that had cost gloria her life
there's no way of knowing what happened
to her exactly but considering how
bruised up her body was when we found
her it was easy to make an educated
guess she'd gotten bum rushed by the
staff and beaten to death before she
could have even mustered up a defense it
was a horrible way to go we tried giving
her a dignified funeral as we could
given the circumstances buzzing her up
in a body-sized box that was the day i
decided to stop just trying to survive
and start trying to escape i owe that to
brenda if she really had gotten out i
couldn't keep her waiting but i wouldn't
be alone as it turns out another two
members of the little ikea community i'd
come to know were willing to risk it all
with me a man named kelvin and a young
woman named vicky they were sick of just
waiting around fending off attacks from
the staff night after night they both
told me they'd rather die during an
escape attempt than while cowering under
a pile of cheap rugs and so each armed
with claw hammers from the six-piece
ikea fixa tool kit and as many prota
tupperware containers full of meatballs
that we could carry we set off into the
great unknown of ikea we traveled for
weeks marking our tracks on the ground
with the mala mix colors chalk selection
so we never got caught going in circles
one day bled into the next nights were
spent trying to hide in closets and
bathtubs while the staff hunted
relentlessly for people just like us
every single time we got lucky that is
until day 41. here's something you need
to know about the infinite ikea you're
probably already aware if you're
watching this that the 24 hour cycle of
night and day is dictated by the store
lights up above but the space between
day and night isn't a gradient here it's
a cliff you can be minding your own
business when suddenly pitch darkness
and now the staff are on your ass that's
exactly what happened on day 41. we're
in the middle of a kitchenware selection
surrounded by a few docile members of
staff when suddenly the lights switched
off and they went hostile on us they
look pretty goofy after the initial
shock has worn off but believe me when i
say that these monsters can really pack
a mean wallop when they want to and we
received a reminder of this unfortunate
fact that night the staff swarmed us
repeating that awful phrase the store is
closed you need to vacate the premises
while they struck and flailed at us if
it wasn't for our trusty claw hammers we
would have been dead that night
thankfully we were able to give better
than we were getting we managed to kill
a decent number of staff members and
then make a run for a section with
better hiding places myself vicki and
calvin all stowed away in a large
wardrobe until we saw light flickering
through the crack in the door like we
were rejected extras for some painful
community theater take on the chronicles
of narnia but while we survived that
night we didn't survive unscathed my
face was swollen from a nasty punch one
of the staff members dealt me and from
the pain in my chest i might have been
dealing with a few broken ribs kelvin
sprained his ankle during the escape and
vicki had a cut on her forehead from
when one of the staff members need her
in the face during the fray you never
win these fights he just survived them
we made a temporary camp in the area
where we could rest and recover as well
as shaking off the justifiable fear of
death or grievous harm that dampened our
resolve to get out of this place that
took us to day 53 of course food was
always a concern i don't want to
romanticize what happened in there as
much as i'm sure someone on the outside
might want to imagine this whole
experience as some kind of exciting
survival horror game but i assure you it
was less survival horror and more
survival and horror meaning not only are
we suffering from constant fear stress
and paranoia for our safety in here but
we also need to keep ourselves fed and
watered you're just as likely to die
from starvation in here as you are to be
beaten to death we went in search of
another ikea kitchen where we could fill
up on more water and meatballs your
lifeblood in a place like this it took
us several more days of searching and
hiding searching and hiding before we
hit pay dirt by the time we actually got
our hands on the food and water we were
starving and practically coughing up
dust those meatballs were the most
delicious food i've ever tasted and i
could tell from their faces that calvin
and vicky felt exactly the same way
though at the moment i told myself if no
when i get out of here i'd never eat
another meatball it'd probably give me
war flashbacks or i guess store
flashbacks we filled up our tupperware
and shoved them back into our kia
proving backpacks then we needed to keep
moving keep searching and keep marking
the ground behind us as we fanned out
into the great flat pack yonder avoiding
confrontations wherever we could three
of us still had no idea what insanity
was waiting for us out there we had no
idea that there were even more dangerous
things than the staff lurking in the
shadows day 68 of course i kept count
writing it down on the back of my jetlag
coloring book trust me when every night
could mean a horrible death you keep
track of the nights not a single one of
them escapes you at a certain point i
think we all adapted in our own way it
was back to caveman times again learning
to be like our primal ancestors hiding
away from the dark and the monsters that
hid there so it was extremely surprising
for us to get the most brutal attack
during the day at first i thought we
were being attacked by the staff during
daylight hours like a bolt from the blue
that's when we noticed they weren't
attacking with their hands they were all
holding kitchen knives holding us up
like bandits that's when we realized
what actually happened here we weren't
being attacked by the staff we were
being attacked by other humans dressed
like the staff wearing their
hollowed-out heads like grizzly masks
they told us that we were coming with
them and if we resisted they'd cut us to
ribbons and seeing as none of us were
movie action heroes we thought it'd be
best to do exactly what they said this
is how we fell into the clutches of
general issimo vardagen day 69 but
things were not nice i mean i get it
yeah funny nice i don't know if i'd
mentioned this before but the community
i became part of in the infinite ikea
after meeting gloria was just one of
many nobody knows exactly how many
people are trapped in here i'm hardly a
martyr for spending 68 days in there i
know people have been trapped in there
for years who've given all hope of
escape and accepted their lot in life
they became the elders of a lot of these
communities helping others adjust though
of course generalissimo vardagan was not
one of these people myself vicky and
calvin were dragged by the strangers
dressed as staff members into a fort
made of smashed up wood nailed together
into a huge ominous structure it was a
far more extensive structure than any of
the communities i'd visited or even
heard about before in the infinite ikea
it was a true fortress guarded by many
more of those knife-wielding people
dressed in the clothes and in the flesh
of the staff it looked like some evil
cult straight out of a damn horror movie
i'd never seen anything like it we were
dragged into a kind of tent in the
middle of the camp made out of stitched
together rugs that's where we met
generalissimo verdagen surrounded by his
guards i'd later learn his namesake was
a set of steak knives stocked in the
ikea kitchenware sections similar to the
knives being wielded by his gallery of
goons the generalissimo himself was
dressed like some absurd tin pot
dictator wearing a silly hat and a
jacket covered in fake metals his whole
presence felt like a cosmic punishment
for daring to believe things couldn't
get any more absurd than they already
were his men forced us down onto our
knees and vardagen cleared his throat to
speak quake in the fear as the sight of
this ikea's ruler the great and powerful
generalissimor vadagen i have united
kingdoms from the gardening and bathroom
supplies departments and crushed
descending tribes in the office
furniture sections to the best if you
wish to live you will swell filthy to me
and join my legion of servants if you do
as i say you will be given safety and
security from this staff come nightfall
if you do not depends in me i will have
you destroyed by the time his little
spiel was done the man was red in the
face and sweating profusely it was clear
that much like your average ikea
shelving unit after a couple weeks of
use the great generalissimo vardagen had
a few screws loose none of us liked the
idea of becoming slaves to some
flat-packed genghis khan so we tried to
persuade him to just let us go telling
him that we hoped to escape the store
and with our help he could escape too
that's when we learned a sobering lesson
for some people life inside the infinite
ikea was better than life outside in the
real world the generalissimo had been a
twice divorced ex-salary man with
nothing to his name but debts and
regrets but here he was a demigod a
leader among the rest of us mere mortals
why would he ever want to go back to the
world that had given him nothing and
taken everything day 70 to day 84 we
were forced into weeks of hard labor
after that toiling under the
generalissimo and his gang of brigands
the soldiers worked us like dogs making
us carry food and furniture back to the
generalissimo's scandinavian furniture
fortress one day bled into the next the
best i could say about any of this was
at least we were safe behind the walls
of the fortress at night so we didn't
need to worry about getting murdered by
the staff in our sleep however tragedy
struck again on day 85. calvin couldn't
take the work anymore one day i think
his mind just snapped he refused to
follow orders from the generalissimo and
his lieutenants even when they
threatened him with death sadly that
night they would prove that this wasn't
just some empty threat when night fell
they tied up kelvin's arms and legs and
left him outside the fortress we were
just forced to watch as the staff
assembled and beat our friend to death
while he lay there unable to defend
himself even in all the time i'd spent
in the infinite ikea that was the most
harrowing thing i'd ever seen but in one
of the few acts of righteous cosmic
justice that we'd seen since being
trapped in here all those months ago
just a few days after kelvin's brutal
execution day 90 the day of the
revolution while i'd love to tell you
that i started this there are no heroes
in this story i just happen to be the
one telling you about it some internal
conflict between the generalissimo and
his men boiled over into a kind of civil
war that tore the fortress apart from
within vicky and i escaped but in
different directions i'd like to imagine
she got out in the end it helps me sleep
at night but one thing i will tell you
generalissimo verdagan found out what
happened to tyrants big and small when
his closest confidants give him the
julius caesar treatment with the knives
from which he took his name i don't
think there's anything wrong in taking a
little joy in that for days afterwards i
just walked i felt so empty but i
refused to just lay down and let myself
die even though so much of the hope had
been beaten out of me i couldn't betray
brenda by just giving up in here it
wouldn't be right it just wouldn't be
right the days ticked on and nothing
changed i had no food no weapons and i
was getting so tired then night fell and
the staff started chasing me they seemed
even more aggressive than before i
couldn't fight all i could do was run i
ran and i ran and i ran not even looking
where i was going as the crowd of staff
started catching up with me getting
closer and closer i ran until there was
a doorway before me i didn't even think
i just was trying to get away that's
when i noticed that the store's roof was
no longer above me for the first time in
100 days i was once again tasting fresh
air that's right folks on day 100 i was
out i truly made it out this victory
however was short-lived a group of about
six staff members burst out of the front
door behind me charging towards me with
ferocious speed i couldn't move all i
could do was grip my teeth and wince
ready to accept my death at what had
otherwise been the high point of my
recent life
what a depressing irony that would be
but instead gunshots rang out through
the air a hail of bullets cleaved
through the staff members dropping them
to the ground mere feet away from me
stone dead that's when i turned to see a
group of men with assault rifles and
tactical gear walking towards me in any
other situation this might have been
terrifying but right then it was the
happiest moment of my life these men
took me away from the parking lot of
what is now an abandoned ikea they told
me they were from a group called the scp
foundation and that i'd been declared
missing for some time now i didn't care
about any of that i just asked them if
brenda had gotten out if she hadn't
escaped two then this was all for
nothing you can't even imagine my relief
when they told me that brenda was never
even trapped she was the one who
reported my disappearance after i
dropped off the face of the earth and
what she thought was a perfectly normal
ikea shopping session before that
building was shut down and cordoned off
under some less insane pretense but
brenda was alive and safe and i'd get to
be with her again i have no shame in
telling you i cried but i'd like to
specify that they were absolutely tears
of joy the men from the scp foundation
told me that they'd give me a medicine
that had helped me forget all this after
i told them my story and there's no part
of me that has a problem with that some
things are better left forgotten but
before the scp foundation wipes it all
away from my mind and i get to go live
with my beloved wife once more this was
how i survived 100 dreadful days in the
infinite ikea now go check out how to
actually beat scp-3008 the infinite ikea
and surviving inside scp-3008 the
infinite ikea for more of this swedish
flat pack hellscape